in Kenya's vast lake nakuru national
park the government uses helicopters to
herd track and tagged a rhino population
that's disappearing fast in the last one
year I think we have lost close to 70
rhinos in this country which is a
significant population because that is
about ten percent of the population we
have in this country which is a
population of about 640 animals the
poaching crisis is fueled by the
thriving global market for illegal
wildlife Vietnam is ground zero for the
trade of rhino tusks a single horn can
fetch $300,000 for its perceived
medicinal powers including the belief
that it cures cancer well organised
highly dangerous crime syndicates keep
the Asian markets applied at Smuggler's
turn to more sophisticated methods now
the authorities are perfecting their
response with an ambitious plan to
relocate and tag rhinos with permanent
microchips that may one day crushed the
illegal trade we have actually provided
1000 chips which is more than the number
of finals we have in this country the
plan is any ivory that intercepted will
be able to be traced to the animal that
it came from which directly leads you to
weigh it has come from so we know that
this problem is happening all over
Africa I mean the range estate another
particularly South Africa Kenya may be a
lazy bad way so we'll be able to
depreciate the sources so that we know
where to concentrate our efforts Kenya's
Wildlife Service now uses night-vision
goggles to catch poachers among other
sophisticated techniques but it is
counting on a bit of old-fashioned
thinking to make sure this species
survives after the rhinos are tagged
they're ferried to safety in other parks
across Kenya where they are paired with
the opposite sex to allow mother nature
to work her magic Zeb Eckert Bloomberg